hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast light sheet microscopy
for tissue clearing applications and 3d
live fluorescent imaging presented by
john chen from the Research Center for
Applied Science academia sinica Taiwan
lon Greenbaum from the California
Institute of Technology and Orla hand
man from on door technology we are
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by leverage and
sponsored by on door technology on door
is a world leader in scientific imaging
spectroscopy solutions and microscopy
system in 2014 on door we required by
Oxford Instruments leading provider of
high technology tools for industry and
research to learn more about on door
please visit www or collaborates and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the green eat
Q&A button located in the lower left of
the presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen will answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right finally if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button to let us know
that you're having a problem thank you
now I'd like to introduce dr. V zhang
chen yan chen received his BS and ms
degrees from the chemistry department of
national taiwan university in taiwan in
2001 and 2003 respectively for the MS
work he worked on the nether porous
material synthesis under the supervision
of professors Jungian mal in spring 2014
he became an assistant research fellow
at the Research Center for Applied
Science academia sinica in
one is interested in developing fast low
phototoxicity multi-color and 3d
detection or fluorescence living
specimens which subcellular resolution
imaging tools please join me in
welcoming bijan chen i will now turn the
presentation over ten thanks for
introductions so my name is my great
pressures like I can gather research I
have done in dr. aerobatic group and the
project will be the let it slide shoot
microscopy and I will focus on how we
develop her the technique and what's the
application for lads so the ladies like
[ __ ] microscopy is simply for 3d 54
essence Imaging's so when we talk about
love for races then we will know there's
always a lot of trade-offs for the life
for recent images especially for a
special resolution for imaging tests and
for the temporal resolution and of
course because we are now talking about
life so data phototoxicity which is most
key please quickly most of time here in
all experiments and because we are doing
the four SS so all the parameters should
be based on the photon budget if you
have unlimited photon budget then you
can do a lot of things to get a very
good resolutions in spatial and time and
also the test so what's the challenges
for life images of course we know the
simples are alive and they are dynamic
so that means your imaging speed should
be fast enough to catch the old emotions
to avoid the motion blurring so the
imaging speed should be fast enough and
the second we really need a 3d
resolution because now everybody talking
about 3d imaging and most of time in my
card copy the actual resolution it's the
most words part so a lift how to
isotropic resolution in
three-dimensional destined for we want
to do and the third one we have a
limited proton budget because each photo
for can we meet how many photons is
already determined by the Moloch
yourself so how can we manipulate all
this photons budget over time when we
doing a fine images and the last one is
aberrations cooking skill all optics
because when we use the light and the
light should be penetrate through the
tissue and as we know later scattering
assertions so the operations all of this
will be kind of problematic for life
imaging's so these are all the changes
so the technique that we invent further
we call the 20 relations what's the
difference from the plane inventions but
as the happy illuminations if you do can
learn terrain ranges the praying nations
will be like two objectives and these
two objective will be also going to each
other so we send if we separate
excitation and detection so if you look
it from we can send a laser from the
side and this side which is a plane and
this plane is the focal plane of your
educational objectives so that means we
can simply look at one point by point
and full addy inventions ap inventions
we have like a single objective we shine
a laser and we correct the ledger from
all the tabs so that means there is no
optical sectioning full appeal nations
but the good thing for the plane nations
we have a very good optical sectioning
capabilities and we can improve the
actual resolutions which is what we most
concerned when the good thing for
pollination and applications we have a
very good imaging speed because we use
the wide field detection so for the next
slides that we will see a key trade off
so there are a lot of different type of
relations and what's the trade-off so
that the laser trade-off for the life
sheet thickness and the field of view so
if you look at least our flights we will
we send the excitation we make a
citation a very small article spots and
then we can create a long like [ __ ] but
the problem is the sickness the sickness
will be fat so this is kind of it needs
a fat that means is kind of why feel
again so that means your actual
resolution will not as good as the
single sheet but if you want to make a
single sheet then what you will have is
a field of you become smaller so these
two other trade off so long I sheet and
the thickness is sick and small as [ __ ]
and you have a very good optical session
so these are the kind of shadow patrina
what we call a Gaussian license so in
how people know aerobatic grouped we
invent another optical properties we
call the vessel being in citations so
the pencil beam it's kind of ring a
citation over here so if you send a ring
then actually L focal point is a vessel
function so the objective is self is
doing the Fourier transform so if you
send a ring citation after the Fourier
transform it's a bessel function the
pencil function it's very long and very
thin like [ __ ] so this for this kind of
like [ __ ] then we can gather quite a
large field of view and a very good
article section so that's why first we
do the peso p my cost copy so this is
kind of lives that we compare a gaussian
and the pencil and two-photon pencil if
you look in the gaussian accounting long
and the problem is that it's the facts
so the actual actual resolution is not
as good
that's our being but there is a problem
for the pencil beam is there a lot of
concentric ring if you see in the middle
of this slice then you will see a lot of
concentric green this consent your green
quickly real cause the background for us
so the first time we know okay how can
we how can we remove the background so
then we use the non-linearity from the
optics so we use the pulse later and
then we use the two-photon properties by
two photon because of non-linearity we
can do the intensity square so if you
have i square simply we suppress the
background pilot two-photon bezel so
this is the first technique that we
remain for the two bottom bezel so this
is a single beam so single being how can
print create a plane so we scan a pin
very fast back and forth so by this way
we can create a time average /
innovations so this is one directions
for the next we will see a movie so for
the actual resolutions know so we can do
a scanning so you will see the the
optical scanning is further synchronized
the objectives game so you will feel of
excitation for the laser and then the
objective here is the focal plane of the
excitation laser beam so by this way we
synchronize these two then we can see
the 3d scanning falla by this way this
is we call after tips game and the
others can involve which we will see in
the next movie is the simple scanning so
simply we can move the central we didn't
move any optics so we simply that move
the temple itself so palace to we can
get a really good 3d of our imaging
stylish way so that's
so what's the another kind of
manipulation that we can do is full fat
soybean because pencil beam has a creep
pre patent so this pattern is that we
can create some specific frequency
pattern so we can use the gobble meteor
the gamma real will be kind of set
bounds and off on and off on and off so
to create some frequency under
excitation so this is what we call the
pencil beam super-resolution pilot
structural nations so if you look at the
special function and then if you use a
cover to step on and off we can create a
pencil fi structural asian excitation so
as you can see this intent intensity
play laser frequency so this frequency
can be applied to your sample and your
sample can have moderated by this
citation pattern and if you module then
we can get a lot of exposure we can go
Taylor excitations and then we can get a
lot of exposure and then we can
reconstruct the super-resolution imaging
so you can see here later cell this cell
has a two color label h2b and might
accomplish metal cube microtubules so
this is the 3d super-resolution imaging
based based on the path of being excited
shins so not just a single pin if you to
blur the what's the problem for a single
being eat because if you our exposure
time is less and less then each beam
stay a one particular positions will be
very very short that means our signal to
noise ratio is less so in order to
improve our signal to noise ratio we
have to put a lot of laser power so that
means we will kill our samples so the
phototoxicity and photodamage will
happened so how about we can create a
market being simultaneous five octaves
so this is kind of the benefit for the
market being first
is the images speak because we have
market being so the new genes p should
be fast and second actually the photo
damage right now we distribute one beam
energy too many big energy so simply we
divide that one over end of your number
of your beans then we can keep the same
signal to noise ratio but we still keep
the simple very happy so this is a speed
and photo damage and then this is kind
of first demonstrations for our
marketing vessel when we see them
multipath of beings excitations so this
is the seven parallel pencil beans with
the diffractive optical elements and we
use the diffractive optical elements by
police are passive optics the reason I
call a pacifist we cannot change it
because this is a feat cooperating so we
put a vessel and so being a la masque
and then we have a diffractive optical
element by this way we can split one bin
27 beans so if you look at this
intensity plot from the left panel you
can see all the different vessels
there's distance separations around 10
microns from each other so late no
income interference between each other
this all are seven identical peso beings
so by this way we already demonstrated
the membrane we can see even larger
field of view and we can have a faster
scanning and we reduce the photo damage
that's the most important week reducer
for total energy so that means we can
image you the tempos even don't good so
this is the first time we say okay how
about we do the monkey puzzle things but
we want to make even more beans for
example like hundred beans like 200
beans right
hard to the passive optics from the
gratings so which we figure out a way we
use the spatial light modulator so as
you can see from this movie you can see
this is a paso so the tassel is a data a
lot of concentric green we know but the
problem is the backgrounds and we we
looking it up
you
so as you can see from the movie if you
can control the distance between each
battle things then you can have a very
very good optical properties record
interference as you can see the pattern
of the intent that the intensity pattern
if you keep changing so you can feel a
different a distance have some different
interference patterns and some specific
distance for example that this case
around point 9 1 micron all the bezel
being has a constructive interference
and the center and destructive
interference from the side so that is
way we can create a market beam vessel
and we can also reduce the background
from the cycle so the problem is how to
create this kind of pattern because we
know the type optics doesn't work so we
go to the active optics we call a
spatial light modulator so this is kind
of scheme for the proposed that set up
so you can see we have a binary spatial
light modulator here from the fourth
dimensions so we calculate intensity and
we kind of know the face of from the
intensity and then we apply this pattern
to the spatial fly moderators and we
have so after the first lens then you
can get this kind of diffraction
patterns and after the mosque weekly out
unwanted higher-order depressions and we
have a two-cobber mineral conjugate each
other once again the extraction the
other ones can the three directions and
then we conjugate this pattern to the
excitation and mystery citation as
written we see they are supposed they
are also Cano to each other and it is a
point spread function that we can get
from the optics from the microscope so
the dry one he does theoretical
calculation
and the major experimental data and so
you can see the match pretty well so
this is what we kind of first-time
demonstrator Maki a beam and then as
hoping and then they are doing a
coherent interference so these are all
instrumental data so as you can see
there's a single pencil and then a
different distance they have a different
interference patterns and for this one
is you can see from like a 1.6 micron at
this case the background from the Bessel
function as oppressed and all the energy
are concentric Ellis Center so this is
what we want and these are all the
experimental data and the reason we call
it as a lattice citations that is like
[ __ ] because right now we can simulate
any kind of lattice pattern and then we
apply to the spatial image rate X and
then we can get this kind of intensity
pattern on the focal point of excitation
objective so as you can see these are
hexagonal or cubic or square lattice
patterns for all the different of
different purpose and the most important
is this is from X mu Z and if you look
at the scale bar over here is the 2
micron so that means we can control all
the pattern LS the micron positions and
these are really good for the
specialized full of structure invention
because we know the structural nation
needs some frequency and these are all
the frequency from the lattice pattern
which is very good for the structure
invention for a super resolution so here
I will show you how we can construct
this kind of the imaging core of the
lattice like [ __ ] my past copy so we can
send the light from the right the best
one laser excitation objectives and the
detection one is a shoot one is from the
Mekong 1.1 and then you Mike raptures
both of our dependence and
we are doing the line for imaging so we
please to objective inside the imaging
median directory so these two are very
very tight so there's not another enough
space and we customize a five millimeter
cover six so you can see the working
area it's very small and we put a simple
such as a sale or C elegans or zebra
fish on the focal plane and if you look
at a focal plane here we put a dye
solution inside you can see all the
light sheets now we can create a hundred
beams nicest mo taneously and each pin
has a separation from one around like
one micron so this is really good
because now we can improve our image in
speed and we can reduce our for damages
so here I will show you animations for
the how can we get a 3d movie imaging by
our scanning so you can see the
you
so you can see a single this is a
leukemia cell and the fear it's a label
with a membrane marker so as you can see
we have many ping like she so we can
shift we can be dirt a little bit for a
lattice pattern and then we can create a
time-averaged uniform a citation for
this very thing the thickness of his
life sheet point is around half of my
car which is very good for other cell we
can do a sub several resolutions so you
can see we scan the sample and then the
beam is playing doesn't move and this
plane is a wide field plane so can be
captured by the camera so the camera
will see a few a serious over 20 key
data and then we can stack older see a
tutti keep data then we can get a 3d
data for one time point so if you want
to do the time-lapse then we can do such
as the next slide we will see us a movie
for the cell which is moving on top of
cough syrup so this is a movie that we
will see so now we can play the movie
for this
you
so you can see the sale it's kind of
coating on top of the cover slips and if
you look at all the different view angle
we didn't have any space of spatial
resolution distortions so simply we can
get an isotropic resolution and these
keidel subcellular resolution and most
important is if you look at a time stamp
we can finish your 3d imaging f sub
second that's less than a second so we
have a five minute second exposure and
then 150 these lights so we can get a
very good temporal resolution for this
kind of big for this kind of nom nom so
here i will show you like we have 22
scanning mode one is recorded eagled
mode the dealer mode is we can scan the
beam and then get an imaging and the
other one we call a similar structure
invention more we need to apply some
specific patterns we shift their pattern
and we get a data so that is where we
can get an even better spatial
resolution of course we lose some
temporary solution so as you can see
from this movie then we will see the two
different scanning mode the pedo mode
and then the sim mode so now we can play
the movies then we will see what's going
on for this
you
so if you look at the last panel you
will see the dealer mo Creach the time
stamp it with a second second interval
but if you look at the right one the
like a several second like a seven point
five second interval so as you can see
the temporal resolution is different but
the special resolution wise you can hit
the right one the simo has a better
spatial resolutions so let's we were
back to our final slice is again these
words come compromised a large it's
another trader the trainer spatial
resolution and control solution and also
the imaging tests the imaging tests
Creek I didn't cover a lot for this part
we still a lot of research is going on
by using the light sheet and doing the
even deeper tissue for example like a
brain the brain tissue and then we can
look at more to get a very fast imaging
for the entire 3t for the plane
constructions and of course we most of
time we want we want to do the life
imaging so we have a photo tactical team
so again this is a tech home message for
the spatial resolution temporal
resolution imaging tests and
phototoxicity all its parameters should
be based on the photon budget queries
because we are doing the four reasons so
I think they are still a lot of research
rather niche now we can do for all these
parameters and hopefully and all the
researcher from the updates from the
parties ecology and from like a bio
computations we have to jump together to
do another extensive corporations to
make this a beautiful betas work and
thanks for your attention thank you John
Chen for that informative presentation
now I'd like to introduce dr. Alan
Greenbaum dr. Greenbaum with his BS and
ms degrees in electrical engineering
from tel aviv university his PhD in
electrical
gineering from the university of
california los angeles in his doctorate
degree along conducted biophotonics
research under professor I'd wanna know
Shawn focusing on high resolution and
high-throughput microscopy for
biomedical applications in professor
Viviana gratin aroos lab at the
California Institute of Technology is
exploring innovative imaging techniques
for various neural science applications
I will now turn it over to dr. Greenbaum
thank you for the kind introduction so
my advisor is Professor baby i'm a girly
now and i'm from the california
institute of technology today i'm going
to talk about lighting microscopy
Felicia clearing up education I John
professor Viviana could be now love
something like eight months ago and a
bit like [ __ ] for that purpose and they
have we'd like to share with you some of
my experience and some of the technical
challenges that are involved so what is
the motivation behind beeping and I take
my crystal so it all started in 2015 in
the paper from cowardice ojos clouds and
Stanford when they were able to take
care in mouse brain you can see here and
you can see the bits of baked to make it
a transparent as you can see here to the
right the way that they do that they use
a hydrogen scaffold and then they
extracted bleep it out and they made it
to click on spare now the problem is how
the image an entire brain and such a
large volume in the fast way if you're
going to use the confocal it's going to
take something like weeks to image the
entire and brain the problem is even
aggravated as a professor Gordon now
published a paper in which a whole body
clearing which they was able to achieve
using profusion so you can take the
entire mouth and you can include the
entire body of that mouth as you can see
here so you had a brain it took weeks
now you're talking about the whole body
it can take months you know to image and
entire body using
so what is the solution the solution is
to use a light keychain with costco p
it's a fast alternative to confer call
microscope so here we want to look at
very large volume we want to look deep
into the volume into the tissue and we
are not end that butter some
phototoxicity because the cells are
already fixed so this is the main
difference between the previous
presentation and this presentation so
income focal that it said before it's a
point scanner so it's very slow and
lighted microscope its images entire
plane and something like 100 times
faster than a confocal so the way that
the setup works is that you have here
the illumination that is coming from one
direction and you illuminate only one
selective flame and that's provide you a
the same effect that it can sort of
sleep and provides you in a typical
Canseco and the light is detected using
a detection objective which is
perpendicular to the light sheet so how
you implement it so the implementation
is you can either build it yourself
microscope as you can see here to the
right and this is the shoe thermal and
paper he was the first one that was able
to image an entire and mouse brain using
light microscopy in many ways I'm
following his steps and then you have to
commercial product which is thy slightly
one and the with the microscope devout
two ways in order to to build the
lighting go to Bible so i want to show
you how it looks the facts accusation
the facts accusation is there pretty
much as if they're spraying with you
going to see in the movie you can see a
clear the mouse brain it's one
millimeter you can see in the genius
fluorescence so the self-same that
you're going to see on neurons and
they're going to be a white Mindy and
you're going to see 3d rendering so
let's see the movie
you
ok so you so that we are able to get
very fast accusation but then we can
still see the processes and of the cells
and we can get a very good 3d rendering
and of the volume using a 90 so how it's
been done so this is the light
microscope setup as you can see here
it's a relatively simple setup we use a
laser and the laser and project the
Gaussian beam over the gal well a meter
scanner over the galvanometer scanner as
you can see here so it's a Gaussian beam
as they previously talked the food we'd
have maximized usually something like
seven micrometer and the Galvez scanner
just stands the beam up and down and
that creates a similar effect is using a
cylindrical lens in the sense that you
illuminate an entire plane just by
deterring and the Gaussian and beamed up
and down and that's before and provides
more uniform illumination in using a
cylindrical and then and the light is
projected on the sample as you can see
here and the sample sits on an XYZ a
translation stage and perpendicular to
that is the cloudy objective as you can
see here and these are unique objective
they have very long working distance few
millimeters and you have a correction
color that allows you to a correct for
spherical aberration so this I lenses
are a true enablers in order to see deep
into the tissue with almost no beret
shin or minimal aberration and then you
collect the things using a camera so
it's a pretty simple setup however the
synchronization here in an IT quite a
complicated you have three stages you
have the simple stage another for the
excitation length and for the cloudy
objective also sitting on length you
need to synchronize the double scanner
in the camera so most of the things are
being done on software
so the hablar is not complicated the
software is a little bit complicated i'm
using matlab in a micromanager a lot of
people are using LabVIEW the advantages
and disadvantages to either way but you
need to implement many calibration
function you know to make it tool so
what are the important components that
you need in this mess a setup first of
all it's a sample stage in order to
retrieve the frame rate of something
like 45 frames per second I'm using
continuous scanning it means that the
sample is moving continuously while the
camera is capturing images if you're
going to wait until the sample and the
stage is going to settle you won't be
able to retrieve the 45 frames of 50
frames per second Klaus your objective
already talked about it and the camera
is also a very important component so I
prefer to use light cheat mode and
cameras currently I don't have one and
I'm a muscle has one and I would like to
explain what's of their advantages so in
the standard camera your readout is x
direction as you can see here and you
are able to get full frame and with the
frame rate of 100 frames per second in a
light cheatham a camera the readout is
only in one direction you can see over
here so why is it good for us it's good
for us because if you look at the
exposure window over here it just like a
whirling window that goes in that
direction and that fact allows you to
improve this and now of the accusation
and let me show you how so you have the
light sheet and this is the sample
you're going to see the light kit and
this is the exposure window by
synchronizing both the light cheap and
exposure windows you can see here
together than moving together in
synchronized way you'll be able to get a
better SNL and the reason is if you have
synchronized motion you're going to
collect the light that is coming from
these speeds as you can see
however if you would and you won't
collect any scattered light that's
coming from other areas in the image
however if you would illuminate the
entire sample at once you would collect
the scattered light that is coming from
other components and that allows you to
get better contrast the National so this
is continuous scan vs light cheat mode a
scan as you can see here to the left the
image is and blurred in comparison to
the image to the right so how you
synchronize it and i'm going to give two
minutes for the people who actually want
to build a light it especially that it's
not clear from the literature i'm going
to explain how i actually do it so you
have the desktop computer and heat
controls an arbitrary function generator
and the arbitrary junk function
generator and outputs and external
trigger to the camera so an external
trigger is just a series of pulses that
when the camera is given one plus its
integrate only one image the second
signal is going to the Galvez scanner
and this will be minor the guard with
scanner takes the light sheet and moves
it up and down by a according to the
voltage that you provided so the ram
singh them you provided you can see over
here what it does is let's say the
tweeny are in the yellow spot over here
so the light it is going to be in the
upper part of the camera going to be
over here and then if you have the green
spot as you can see here the light it is
going to be in the bottom part of the
camera and what you really want to do is
to synchronize between the right seat
and the exposure window as you can see
over here so in order to do that you
have two degrees of freedom is the ramp
slope which controls the galvo speed or
you can change the delay between a
external trigger and the rent so the day
the way that I do it in MATLAB I have a
synchronous
an algorithm runs iteratively until it
converge so you can use any sample bits
also and find and you pick two bits as
you can see here this is one bit and
this is the second bit and what you are
doing is you change the values of the
delay for each and individual bit and
you want to get the best signal that you
can so if we look at the not
synchronized case you will see that the
die chick is in one place and the
exposure window is in a totally
different place they're going to get a
very low as signal but if the delay is
optimal this is your sample and your
camera is going to record that signal so
you change the delano to optimize and
the signal and you do that for the two
bits if the delay they call it means
that the govern the exposure windows
synchronize if not according to the
delay value you can change it you know
to get and synchronization so you change
the speed between so that's that now I'd
like to show you in this movie again i'm
going to show you very fast approve
dictation of 35 frames per second it's
occlude a right-brain you can the genus
fluorescence and you're going to see
Colin genic a fibers and here so yeah
let's see the movie
okay so i would hate i hope that you
were able to see the fine processes that
we were able to recall in that case it
was four types it will stitch using a
tennis teacher and now i want to show
you a a major issue that i encountered
eugene using a light kit especially for
a clear tissue and especially when
you're going very deep the fact is that
you need to focus the light sheet and to
the m to the focus length of the
detection objective so in light sheet
you need to make sure that the light
itself is going to it coincide with the
focus of the detection objective this
thing you don't have any regular
confocal because they're going to come
focal the light path is shared by so of
excitation and detection ensured that
the same objective so you don't have
this point however using light reach you
might and have the situation especially
deep into a tissue when you have
variation in 54 active index when the
light sheet is in one place however the
detectives objective and focusing is in
a different location and I'm talking
about slight variation of something like
10 micrometers is going to cost the
effect of how to focus image as you can
see here to the top so you need to
compensate for that and the way to
compensate for that is to use auto focus
in the different depth so it means every
time before you're going to apply and
you're going to capture a tie you're
going to use the notification step in
that case you just move half a
millimeter and half a millimeter steps
along your skin and in each deaf people
and you do also focus it means that you
move your objective location and you
look at the images until you get the
best contrast for the image so let's say
that we have the position of the value
that you get from auto focus from zero
and depth half a millimeter depth one
millimeter depth as you can see here you
build a calibration curve and you
interpolate it and these are the red
stuff that you can see over here use
this calibration curve and then you have
a synchronized motion when you scan the
sample between your sample that you
translate it in the continuous mode and
the clarity of dejected so both of them
are going to move in front in a
synchronized way you know to eliminate
this out the focus aberration and all of
the movies that you saw are using them
so autofocus you need to think about
whether you want to use scatter light
versus emitted light and what focus
measured to use and I have to say that
there is no one-size-fits-all solution
especially when you look at different
organ you need to sometimes Taylor the
other focus algorithm to that specific
organ that you looking at so you can
always increase the food we have maximum
of the light it of course in order to
kind of mitigate that problem the thing
is that if you increase the food will
house maxima you lose the signal to
noise and the nice images that you are
able to achieve using an error and light
key so I'm using something like seven
micrometer and just to wrap up this is
the autofocus this is with correction
like the movie that you see and this is
without correction so you can see that
even very small variation of something
like 500 micrometer between a detection
objective in the light weight cause
severe aberration that you net need to
take into consideration so let me
summarize about enlighten some
conclusion it's fast it creates a lot of
data it's relatively easy to build
however it's how to synchronize it
requires proficiency in programming it's
difficult to manage the acquired data
you can either use a computer cluster
and a lot of people talked about the big
data forum that created by a logic
microscopy or you can use commercial
packages like in Mary's own a mirror so
immersed wing design
that it does not teach the images and it
requires multiple conversion like a
fantastic teacher to American someone
however the bottom line is that it's
open new avenues in biology you can see
a very large volumes with a very high
resolution and in 3d and that allows you
to look for very very most illogical
advance so i would like to acknowledge
the people in a professional gardeners
lab and professor go bananas lab for her
guidance and people in a donkey's lab
that is their hosting so i'm building
the nitrogen hitler and of course an
anti lingual so is a technical
professional system this research is
there supported by this funding agencies
and thank you very much that concludes
my presentation if you dr. Greenbaum for
that fantastic presentation now i'd like
to introduce dr. or Allah Hanrahan dr.
Hanrahan has worked with on door
technology as an application specialist
in life science for the past five years
her old room for in touch with all the
latest developments and innovations in
both camera technology and microscopy
applications previous the best dr.
Hamlin managed a microscopy facility in
the biochemistry department at Trinity
College in Dublin where she worked for
the variety of microscopy shut up
including wide field fluorescent
microscopy point scanning confocal
microscopy expending disk confocal
microscopy I will now turn it over to
dr. Hanrahan thank you very much and I'm
delighted to be concluding this web
Laurie today and I'd like to thank mr
tooth presentations already from dr.
Chen and dr. Greenbaum and then both of
them have been using mfc mouth cameras
for their light sheet microscopy so what
I'm going to talk about now is an
Android CMOS camera and Hawaii issues
the camera of choice for this particular
application and so just moving on then
we'll go to the first slide and & S team
of detectives are
I suppose edge detector of choice for a
lot of applications these days and
especially for a light microscopy and
what a CMOS cameras have is there
actually unique in simultaneously
offering extremely low noise so they're
read noise is inherently very low so
they have essentially one electron read
noise and that's what they're having to
use electron multiplication on the chip
which is what is required in an e/m ccd
camera to enable very very low read
noise so these r CMOS chips or in
sensors or cameras and have essentially
extremely low read noise they also have
very very fast frame rates so if you're
using the full field of view so you're
using it as for example 4.2 megapixels
and which is a huge area you can achieve
100 frames per second and that's very
very fast now obviously if you're using
smaller regions of interest you can go
even faster so you have the ability to
get very very fast frame rates and with
very very low read noise and so you
don't have the usual problems but you
might have what a ccd camera when you
read our very fast in a ccg camera your
read noises essentially an increasing
for the faster you readers the higher
the read news however with your FC most
cameras you can read/write extremely
fast and still maintain a very very low
read noise also with these particular
and cameras you have a very wide dynamic
range so the FC mouth cameras allow you
to look at very very low light signals
and very bright light intensities in one
image so a for example if you are
looking and a deep tissue where you do
have a lot of different intensities of
life these cameras are ideal and in
order to be able to see both the dark
under light in one image and also
there's a very high resolution so that
the pixels themselves are quite small
they 6.5 microns in size and you have
4.2 million pixels of this size we've
got a very large fields of you and a
very small and the perfect size of pixel
in order to get the best resolution and
for this type
van microscopy so that's the main
features I suppose of a CMOS and in
terms of the difference between a CMOS
ECG the CCD chip and is a lot slower
than the a CMOS chip it's also got
entire reading always associated with it
and if you look at this diagram here the
CCD chip is on the left hand side and
this CMOS chip is on the right side the
right hand side and in the CCG camera
you have to essentially the in order to
get an image red edge from the sensor
the pixels have to transfer the charge
from row to row so vertically through
the sensor so each row has a transfer at
the photoelectrons from row to row and
it's all done Road by road so they'll
get to the very end and then
horizontally and sent to the reader
register those quite a slow process and
however in your f CMOS chip every pixel
itself is almost like its own sensor so
every pixel and has its own read age and
architecture associated with it but you
don't have to transfer charge from row
to row in your f CMOS chip so everything
happens in the pixel itself and
therefore you get much much higher frame
rate so there's no delays in terms of
vertically shifting the charge to read
the sensor and everything happens in the
pixel itself and therefore you get much
much higher speeds and this then on the
the bottom right of this is an example
of your pixel so you can see that you
have all of your transistors around the
top of the pixel in your esteem of
sensor so with the front illuminated
sensor and whereas EMC cg cameras which
generally have machi illuminated sensors
so the f CMOS sensor is front
illuminated it means that all of the
electronics are covering over and the
top of the pixel therefore and they
could affect the actual social sensitive
area that's available for the light to
enter so what's on top of every single
pixel in your f CMOS chip is a micro
lens so the micro-lens essentially will
focus the light inside
the photosensitive area inside the pixel
so that's your the general parameters
with your f CMOS chip and if we just
move on to the next slide then you can
see that M the vial of 4.2 is the idea
of attack to them for my cheap
microscopy so ang or have and a range of
F CMOS detectors and we have viola 5.5
we have neo 5.5 and we have viola 4.2
and the reason why the side of 4.2 and
edge of the full range of F CMOS is the
ideal detector is first of all because
of its quantum efficiency so it has a
seventy two percent quantum efficiency
and so it's twelve percent higher
quantum efficiency than the other range
of F CMOS chips and this is because it's
a four transistor m-f CMOS camera and
it's because it has essentially lost one
of the transistors or one of the terms
of students from the pixel has been
removed and this means that you don't
have a global sugar reader mode so the
vial of 4.2 has a four transistor and as
CMOS chip its 4.2 mega pixels in size
and it has a rolling shutter only and
exposure mechanism and it has less than
one electron read noise very low to our
current fast frame rates a very wide
dynamic range so I've mentioned the
rolling shutter and mechanism here and
this is a very important in terms of the
lie cheat microscopy and application now
with the other a CMOS chip three have a
five transistor you have an additional
exposure mechanism which is called
global sugar and the global shutter
essentially will and give you all pixels
of being exposed at the same time so
it's a global exposure so all pixels on
the chipper exposed at the same time in
all our red edge at the same time and
I'm going to go into that in a little
bit more detail afterwards but and it's
important to remember that the rolling
shutter mechanism it's what is used and
to synchronize with the life force for
example in your light microscopy it's
wash and our previous speaker dr.
Greenbaum was discussing so it's
rolling shutter mechanism of the viola
4.2 which is essential for this so in
terms of I want to talk about the
rolling and global shutters here so
these are two important mode it's
important to understand the differences
between them and it's something that M
is available on SC monster cameras so
this slide here really shows you the
difference between the two modes so on
an F CMOS camera everything happens from
the center outwards and both directions
so with a bi-directional readout so the
top and area here of the other slide
shows you a rolling shutter exposure and
read a and what actually happens in
rolling shelter is that the first row on
either side of the sensor will receive
light so as soon as light is a mission
from the sample and if you have your
rolling shutter exposure mode turned on
the first row and either side of the
sensor will receive light and and then
it happens from row by row ash words
from the center and there's a 10 micro
second delay from say the first row to
the second row from the second row third
row from the terrarosa fourth row so the
transient exposure so it's not happening
all all pixels are not exposing at the
same time there's a transient exposure
happening when you're using a rolling
shutter mechanism now if you're not
doing for example and synchronized light
geesh and you're using you're looking at
very very dynamic large and moving
objects the rolling shutter mechanism
might not be ideal for you because it's
good cause distortion for example so you
might see a wave instead of a straight
line if you were looking for example at
blood flow so sometimes in some
applications if you're looking at very
very flashed flow movements the rolling
shutter might not be moving the the
movement of the the rose might not be
fast enough and therefore you see
distortion your final image however if
you do want to synchronize the rolling
shutter mechanism with your light source
this is the ideal method to use and
underneath then we have the global
shutter mechanism and this is really
just showing that all pixels are exposed
at the same time they're globally
exposed
they're also all red edge at the same
time so the reed age is global and this
is synonymous with a snap shot mode in a
ccd camera so the zila 4.2 which is the
camera of choice for the light
microscopy applications only has a
rolling shutter mechanism now and this
means that you can easily synchronize to
it with your governor's according to
what dr. Greene mom explained in his
presentation so the next slide then M
has two movies and if you play the
movies we have a rolling shutter and a
global shutter movie
you
you
you
okay so I'm not sure if the second is we
paid Bush i mean the global shutter is
essentially we're all pixels are exposed
at the same time and all pixels are
right at the same time so it's really
just another way of showing you the
mechanism that's taking place on these
cameras when you're exposing and reading
out so on the air the viola 4.2 itself
we do have a light stand mode which
we've applied and this is what and dr.
Greenbaum was discussing during his
presentation and and this is again just
a representation of what actually
happens so you're essentially able to
control how the camera work so you have
a lot more control and flexibility over
the use of the rolling shutter mode on
the camera and what it actually allows
you to do this feature of light scan
plus it allows you to synchronize your
scanning light source to a defined scan
row Heights on the scent on the sensor
so you can decide how wide you want this
exposure window to be so for example you
could hover to be as small as one row or
as wide as the full chip so you could
decide okay i will just want 10 pixels
or 10 rows of pixels to be exposed so
you set the actual width of this and
what it actually does it almost looks or
acts like a confocal slipped detector
and this removes as you focus light so
if therefore provides sharper and more
resolved images so it allows you to
improve the contrast of your final
images by removing Asia focus light and
also with this light gun plus mode you
have multiple rejects available so and
instead of just having your
bi-directional readers which is the
standard reader mode you also have the
ability to use a full length of the
sensor and to redirect from the top to
the bottom or from the bottom to the top
and then you have obviously a few more
modes as well on top of that which will
allow again more flexibility available
to the end user
this is another movie just to show you
how it works so if we can play the movie
please
you
ok so again this is similar to wash and
dr. Greenbaum showed in his presentation
and it's really just to show you how you
can synchronize your light sheet to the
rolling shutter mechanism on the viola
4.2 so what the user has is a full
control over the pixel row Heights the
speed with which you can move this and
split with on the sensor itself and also
the exposure time so if you want to use
very long exposures and you can use very
long exposures and also move the speed
very fast and therefore you're not going
to be M providing a lot of light to your
sample so for example if you have very
very bright and laser light you're using
you can scan very fast so you're not
going to damage your samples you can
control various different parameters
here and giving you an additional
flexibility so the benefits of this are
that your image quality is improved and
because the standover height essentially
acts as a slit detector rejecting
scattered light improving contrast and
signal-to-noise and providing sharper
and more resolved images and finally and
I just want to let you know that and I
know when you're using applications with
like sheesh microscopy you generate huge
amounts of data and as what we have just
introduced recently is a GPU express and
it's essentially a solution for large
data so it allows you to process data on
the fly and it provides a real-time
feedback and optimal data throughput and
accelerated frame rates so essentially
you can take the data that you're only
interested in and as protest that and it
reduces the amount of storage that you
would finally need em for your data so
it's being and we brought it m as with
to work with the SE mas cameras and for
these data-intensive applications like
like cheap microscopy so just like to
thank you very much for your attention
and thought of him my conclusion there
for my presentation thank you dr.
Hanrahan for that informative
presentation time for Q&A if you have a
question you'd like to ask any of our
speakers please do so now just click on
the green shoe in a button the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question in the box that appears on
your screen and click on the send button
or answers many of your questions is we
have time for okay let's get started
first question is can we have slides at
the end of the presentation and that
would be for for either one of you I'm
hoping you can hear me I'll just ask you
that question one more time um one of
the attendees is asking if they can have
slides when the presentation is over oh
sorry yeah yeah so what we'll do I did
here is I have my photo meet there and
we will be providing a recording of the
presentation um and Tony are mortgaging
and Department will we arrange for
empties to be sent out to all the people
who are currently am on the cold so we
will send out a recording of system via
in the next couple of weeks we should
have not great next question are any of
you familiar with clarity flash calm I
was wondering if you had any tips for
imaging large samples for example a full
mouse or rat brain I think alone you
might know a bit more about the the
clarity question yeah so I was basically
talking about that everything that I was
talking about you can take it and you
can extend it so the working distance of
the objective is amusing is a something
like 80 millimeter so you can do the
same thing once you grab one part you
just repeat the whole process again and
again and again until you tell the
entire a brain and the major issue
and you think this approach is how you
end the data because you're talking
about terabytes and terabytes sighs
files that you need to handle them for
visualization and and you know to do
your processing and according to their
biological question that you have in
hand and this is a legitimate paper that
I i mentioned in my presentation next is
help being a live specimen be to use
light sheet microscopy and again that
could be for either of you so alone
idaho you might be better at answering
those things you're into love I general
applies your examples are yeah yeah so I
just want to mention so dr. Chen was
talking about in vivo imaging when you
actually have a life sample in our case
we are using a cleared samples that are
being fixed so i'm not completely
familiar with his setup and i'm not
completely sure what the walking
distance and the objective lens that
they are using and in order to answer
that specifically so yeah i can say that
with cleared samples and your main
limitation is the working distance of
the objective and in that case it can be
up to a few millimeters so it depends on
which objective yes and i even have a
slide that shows a table with the
current available and quality objectives
however am so in vivo application again
it depends on their walking distance of
the objective and i'm not completely
sure that they know dr. Chen set up so I
can answer it
okay here's the next one is it possible
if you clear bone and visualize bone
marrow in the bone without its
extraction so am I prefer not to to
completely address this question this is
the direction that we get a kind of fat
exploring right now but there are ways
to you okay I looked at a time looks
like we may have time for one last
question and this one is for dr.
Hanrahan we have a meal on door camera
by a directional not light sheet reading
not lead sheet read out into the rolling
shutter mode currently installed on our
light sheet rig if i define an ROI and
only the upper half of the fov in a on
borneo camera with the readout still be
bi-directional or would it be single
directional since the ROI is only
defined in the upper half of the fov and
there's a little more there um I'm going
to read it all let me know if you need
need we donate now I said another one
right there saying just wondering if I
can apply the white sheet scanning mode
in neo by only using one half of the
full camera detector where they're
likely be any software firmware upgrade
for neo to enable light sheet flip
detection scanning or for neo yeah so
and unfortunately we the light sconce
mode has only been applied to the side
of 4.2 so we haven't added it to the neo
5.5 so it's not possible to use this
mode on neo and in addition and if you
choose an or oh I in the in one half of
the sensor you still have to read it the
full the full chip after you read it but
if you want to place an aura wide and
get the faster three days you're better
off placing it in the center of the
sensor and putting it half and half on
either side so for example if you had a
200 rohi or oh I that you wants to look
at
and you wanted to get the fastest frame
rates you would push a hundred rose on
the top of the path of the sensor 100
votes on the other side of the half so
it has to be sitting on behalf on the on
the center of the sensor to get the
fastest frame rates but you will still
have to yes so you have to do that and
then the lights concert mode is not on
the oh well thank you once again I would
also like to thank our sponsor on door
technology for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I just want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing for six months from
today's live event you'll receive an
email from lab roots when you know when
this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues and may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon bye